[Musique]
comment vos papilles
[Applaudissements]
tout est un bon entraîneur tarit pas
quotidiennement
est venu vous laissez moi être de petits
voleurs qui ira bien si jesse bien j'ai
des bons d
non mais ça va pas non c'est le flou
ravi d'avoir vu tantôt bonne journée de
classe qui sèment la terreur pour le
printemps 2010 à prix fort sympathique
si c'est ça le pouvoir
et moi je laisse aux bonnes nouvelles
copé je crois en toi
c'est vraiment dommage l'héritier des
pouvoirs du cet enjeu ne ta fausse ne
connaîtra plus de limites sur le gall et
solide pas de bagnole qui es tu
je suis place nette
c'est complexe mais ça signifie le
serpent de couleur noire est l'adjectif
[Musique]
d'accord unis on peut faire quelque
chose de grandiose
non non mais je fais un petit massage
cardiaque qui leur permettent deux est
tombé bien bas m'explique quand les
mythes encore la gamme imac snec se doit
de continuer ouais moi on a la gueule
alto pour toi on passe tout sur la
gueule mais dans le respect